le crem a donc confirmé en fin de
matinée un début de retrait de ses
troupes à l'est de l'europe les soldats
stationnés près des frontières de
l'ukraine ont commencé à rejoindre leurs
garnisons cela était annoncé prévu et
semblait s'étonner un tout à l'heure le
porte-parole du kremlin dénonçant l'
hystérie occidentales sur une supposée
invasion imminente en ukraine on va
retrouver tout de suite pour décrypter
ces propos et cette confirmation elena
volochine notre correspondante à moscou
elena bons jours après la confirmation
de dmitri peskov tout à leur faut-il
comprendre que la désescalade réclamé
souhaitait depuis plusieurs semaines et
bien ça y est on y est
oui sans aucun doute c'est un signal de
d'escalader les chaînes de télévision
russes ont déjà diffusé ces images et
cette déclaration du chef de l'état
major des armées igor konachenkov
annonçant que toutes les divisions
militaires des districts sud et ouest de
la russie allait rentrer dans leur base
de dislocation permanente où l'on a prit
d'ailleurs par la même occasion
l'ampleur de ces exercices militaires et
de ces manoeuvres entamées par la russie
puisque jusqu'à présent moscou était
resté très vague à ce sujet disons
simplement qu'elle faisait ce qu'elle
voulait sur son territoire avec ses
armes et alors même que les observateurs
et les journalistes indépendants
observer cette concentration militaire à
la frontière ukrainienne mais donc c'est
aujourd'hui au moment du retrait ou on
en apprend l'ampleur alors c'est ce
qu'avait demandé effectivement emmanuel
macron le président français lors de sa
visite ici à moscou il ya exactement une
semaine au nom des occidentaux c'est un
signal d'autant plus fort envoyé
aujourd'hui par la russie que même
concernant l'exercice en biélorussie qui
sont prévus pour se terminer le 20
février seulement mais le porte parole
des armées a déclaré qu'une partie des
effectifs militaires étaient déjà en
train de rentrer en russie donc ce sont
des signaux effectivement très positif
hier le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov disait que la
diplomatie avait des chances mais rien
n'est terminé la russie parle bien d'un
retrait partiel et maintiendra une
certaine forme de pression militaire
tant que les pourparlers ne sont pas
terminés et n'a cessé ces annonces
interviennent alors que l'on viens
d'apprendre que la rencontre entre olaf
schulze et vladimir poutine vient donc
tout juste de débuter à à moscou énième
tentative diplomatique
oui effectivement le choc dans une
position indélicate avec la russie
puisque l'allemagne à ce projet épineux
avec moscou de gazoduc north stream 2 un
projet à plusieurs milliards de dollars
dont la construction a été terminée en
septembre dernier et on attendait le
lancement à mais il ne vient pas pas
plus que la certification du gazoduc qui
patine à cause justement de cette crise
donc l'allemand l'allemagne a plus que
quiconque intérêt à l'avoir résoudre par
le biais de la diplomatie parmi les
occidentaux en tout cas néanmoins olaf
scholz a affirmé qu'il venait à moscou
avec l'intention de dire à bladimir
poutine qu'il allait payer le prix fort
en cas d' attaques de l'ukraine en ce
sens l'allemagne s'est alignée
évidemment sur la position des
occidentaux hier à kiev olap chose
disait aussi au président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky que l'union
européenne était déjà en train de
préparer et d'affiner des sanctions très
dures envers la russie en cas d'attaqué
ukrainienne cependant à aucun moment il
ne dit exactement quelles sanctions il
qualifie cela de vagues stratégique
laissant entendre qu'il ne faut pas
dévoiler à vladimir poutine toutes ses
cartes donc les auspices de ces
pourparlers
aujourd'hui à moscou sont favorables
mais ce qu'on attend en réalité en tant
que nouvelle étape dans ce dossier c'est
surtout la réponse russe annoncé hier
par sergueï lavrov qu'elle allait venir
cette réponse aux à la réponse des
américains aux garanties dites de
sécurité exigées par la russie qui exige
notamment le nom élargissement de l'otan
aux pays d'ex-union soviétique et à
l'ukraine donc les américains ayant
donné une fin de non recevoir à moscou
cette fois moscou va répondre à cette
fin de non recevoir et c'est sans doute
dans cette réponse qu'on pourra lire
quelques nouveaux signaux en ce qui
concerne la suite à des événements merci
beaucoup et léna volochine un premier
mail